[Musica]
buonasera grazie per essere qui mi sento
un po come alla recita di scuola perché
ci sono a mio padre mia madre di è la
prima volta che parlo davanti a mio
padre mia madre
da quando sono quando mi sono tolto il
motto io sono di caltanissetta quindi
sono più o meno vostro conterraneo vivo
a milano da 11 anni
nel settembre del 2015 dopo qualche anno
che viveva già a milano ho perso casa e
lavoro in soli cinque giorni vi posso
assicurare che questa storia è basata su
una proprio su fatti realmente accaduti
prima venerdì sarà il mio padre ex
padrone di casa mi dice che avrei dovuto
lasciare l'appartamento in cui vivevo
per una questione di
affitto voleva che aumentare il canone
io me lo potevo permettere cinque giorni
dopo incredibilmente l'azienda per cui
lavorava per un'azienda di e commerce
facevo il copywriter ha chiamato tutti
in in adunata tramite un'email e ha
detto ha comunicato che avrebbe
licenziato diverse persone ovviamente
usando tutta una serie di metafore
soprattutto quelle marchette tipiche
dell'aziendalismo no perché i mon fuori
c'è un mondo che vi aspetta si vabbè
quindi persa a casa il lavoro
io avevo aperto nel 2012 un blog non
proprio di cucina che si chiama uomo
senza tonno che è diventato anche il mio
diciamo nome nome d'arte
e cominciò a fare dei piccoli
investimenti sui sui social su facebook
su instagram però è più devo dire che mi
hanno detto che non mi potevo muovere
tanto in questo cerchio però devo dire
che abbastanza confortevole grande mi
posso muovere per fortuna
quindi comincio a fare questa questo
lavoro diciamo di marketing sui social e
ad aprile del 2016 una signora che mi
segue che mi seguiva mi contatta in
primato è mi chiede se fossi interessato
a cucinare a casa sua perché voleva
organizzare una cena con degli amici è l
seccava cucinare allora detto perché non
vieni tu visto che mi piace molto quello
che fai io francamente non avevo mai
cucinato
per altre persone al di fuori dei miei
amici che se li avessi mai avvelenati
alla fine non è che succedeva granché
tanto erano amici ci abbassavamo con due
birrette basta invece andare a cucinare
delle persone degli estranei e fatti
anche pagare un obolo diciamo così dire
simbolico mi aveva un po riempito di
aspettative anche un po di ansia
la serata è andata bene e siccome avevo
fatto il copywriter e allora ho detto
questa carta un po mela giocosi social è
cominciato a spingere questa cosa il
cuoco a domicilio
in una sorta di operazione di marketing
però è fruttata perché poi io sono
diventato è diventato il mio lavoro che
poi ho cominciato a integrare grazie ai
lavori da influenze sui social con con
dei brand
e basta finché è poi arrivata la
pandemia un po mi sono scocciato a fa il
cuoco adesso mi sono trasferito nel
magico mondo del videomaking quindi ho
cominciato a fare a scrivermi video a
registrarli a interpretarli da sola
editarli faccio sostanzialmente un
lavoro da casa editrice la casa di
produzione perdono per me cucina a
domicilio significa scuola ho fatto in
maniera autodidatta mi sono dovuto
creare un mio metodo e cucinare a
domicilio è saper cucinare un piatto
ovviamente commestibile ma anche diciamo
esteticamente buono
esteticamente bello in qualsiasi
condizione con qualsiasi in qualsiasi
ambiente con qualsiasi utensile fornelli
che ti ritrovi che possono essere
induzione o a gas con qualsiasi forno
che per me era sono i dei mostri i forni
perché una volta di cuocere un po più
indietro una volta ci mette 20 minuti al
treno altra volta finalmente 10 quindi
un miliardo e mezzo di ale e nel
frattempo mentre devi tenere tutte le
colle con le cotture
d'occhio c'è il cliente che ti parla ma
non è che vuole sapere cosa stai facendo
ti sta facendo una conversazione in cui
magari stiamo parlando di libri di
cinema dei fatti suoi e quindi io dovevo
come dire disseminare in tanti punti
della
della casa di una casa che non era mia
tutta la mia attenzione quindi ho dovuto
far filare tutte le mie abilità di
di adattarmi ma anche di essere
flessibile io che comunque non pensavo
di essere così flessibile ma inoltre
cucinare a domicilio mi ha insegnato che
i procedimenti non possono essere sempre
standard siccome dovevo fare questi
piatti un po dovunque anche dentro uno
sgabuzzino con un fornello da campeggio
ho dovuto mi sono dovuto slegare dai
procedimenti delle ricette e creare i
miei procedimenti per creare dei piatti
che fossero gustativa mente
come dire complessi però con dei
procedimenti semplificati
quindi per me cucinare non abbia dato
più seguire la ricetta del libro bensì
risolvere una concatenazione di problemi
ciò non vuol dire che ogni volta che mi
metto a cucinare mi viene il mal di
testa ma io fisso degli obiettivi cosa
voglio ottenere da questo piatto voglio
più cita voglio più dolcezza voglio
determinate consistenza e come ci arrivo
a questo piatto qua e questo ovviamente
è stato anche aiutato dal fatto che ho
assaggiato tante cose nel corso degli
anni e quindi ho creato un archivio che
vi permette di poter poter prendere una
così una grande dispensano e lo stesso
lavoro che anche fanno i sommelier
sostanzialmente non è un lavoro di
memoria che ricercano dei profumi che tu
magari diceva come odore di pellame
andato ad annusare l'anno di un cavallo
ma no invece sostanzialmente c'è quella
quel sentore perché ci sarà sicuramente
qualche qualche molecola che la richiama
ma
la il mio iter però lavorativo non è
stato lineare io ho il mio grande sogno
da bambino era quello di fare il
musicista ho fatto quattro album sono un
cantante di qui un disco lo ha fatto da
solista lo composto senza saper suonare
nessuno strumento tanto meno conoscere
lo spartito sondato orecchio per il
disco era giusto perché poi lo ho
affidato le demo a un produttore mi ha
detto funzionanti ci posso lavorare
ho iniziato a lavorare a 14 anni
perché a casa sempre andato uno
stipendio e quindi quando volevo
comprarmi qualche cosa ho deciso di
andare a guadagnare un po la pagnotta
durante l'estate ho fatto il muratore ho
fatto l'elettricista ho fatto il
cameriere per 12 anni o
recensioni museo scritto tante molte
recensioni musicali per diversi anni ha
poi fatto il copywriter con la per
l'azienda per cui lavoravo che poi mi ha
licenziato
la cucina domicilia arrivato un po un po
per caso ma ognuna di queste di queste
di questi lavori che ho fatto mi ha
sempre lasciato qualcosa anche quando
quel lavoro mi faceva schifo anche
quando pensavo che non mi sarei mai
portato nel suo insegnamento da quella
da quell'attività
aver fatto il cameriere per molto tempo
c'è stato un periodo in cui lo faceva in
un ristorante pizzeria e posso
assicurarvi che il periodo marzo maggio
era la discesa dell'inferno in terra
perché c'erano i banchetti e le
comunioni delle cresime e quindi si
attaccava alle 8 del mattino e fino alle
2 di notte molto spesso c'erano venti
minuti 30 minuti di pausa in cui tu
dovevi mangiare l'avanzo è rimasto e non
avevi il tempo di fermarsi perché dovevi
risistemare subito la sola perché alle
sei e mezza dove avere già di nuovo la
sua pronta e quindi mi ha infuso un po
il senso della fatica del fatto che
finché il lavoro non è finito non si
finisce adesso lavorando sui social come
micro influencer faccio comunque dei
video è che non ho degli orari lavoro a
progetto e quindi questa cosa me la sono
portata in questo nuovo lavoro fare aver
scritto musica mi ha insegnato che
comporre un piatto è un po come scrivere
una canzone gli ingredienti sono delle
note che io devo prendere arrangiare
affinché dentro la bocca tutti i sapori
suonino bene fare è stato un copywriter
mi ha aiutato a
a vendere i miei contenuti sui social a
vendere il mio servizio di cuoco a
domicilio a cercare di farlo capire a
persone che non l'avevano mai sentito
francamente quando ho cominciato nemmeno
non sapevo che esistessero i cuochi a
domicilio
ma cucinare a domicilio mi ha lasciato
un'altra
grande eredità che ho portato dalla
cucina me la sono portata nella vita
quotidiana
dovendo fare tutto da solo perché non sa
non avevo dei collaboratori
dovevo
[Musica]
avevo quindi anche una scaletta molto
molto stretto di tempi in un ambiente
che non conoscevo dovevo selezionare
attentamente i miei pensieri
dovevo essere molto concentrato come di
dover solo in campo frugale nel capire
quale fosse l'unico pensiero su cui
catalizza rwe e lasciare tutto il resto
fuori se tipo se ed è successa questa
cosa se fossi stato in ritardo avessi
commesso un errore mi fossi focalizzato
sul fatto di commettere un errore di
essere in ritardo non avrei mai portato
a termine la cena quindi ho dovuto
asciugare tantissimo il mio modo di
pensare e soprattutto cucinare a
domicilio mi ha insegnato a tenere a
bada la paura l'ansia ma soprattutto la
paura di sbagliare e ho appena detto
tenere a bada e non superare perché
ritengo che le paure non si non si
superino piuttosto si impara a gestirle
le persone coraggiose non sono quelle
che non provano paura piuttosto la
provano ma non se ne lasciano dominare e
quindi poi agiscono
io adesso lavoro nel nel magico mondo
dei della dei social
l'influenza il micro influencer e
sociali sono un mondo veramente
non dico 3 è bello ma nel contempo
tremendo perché di base sponsorizzano
questa sorta di felicità c'è la felicità
di base è un sentimento c'è un'emozione
temporanea certo quando incontri una
persona sei felice in quel momento se
sorridente ma se stai 5 ore sempre
felice a dire a quella persona che sei
felice d'aver incontrato personalmente
gliele voglia di dargli in a tempo lata
vattimo rilassi togliti questo questa
paresi facciale magari adesso sei
contento se saranno ma non sei felice
invece i social vendono la felicità come
una condizione sociale come uno status
se non sei felice sei uno sfigato
probabilmente non hai fatto abbastanza
carriera probabilmente se un perdente
non ti sei impegnato abbastanza
e in più questa competizione questa gara
questo attizzare costantemente questo
fuoco della felicità anzichenò rende le
persone invidiose competitive e accresce
l'ansia che poi viene colmata con
l'identificarsi in un modello di vita
che sostanzialmente non è il nostro o
comunque con l'accumulo di cose in cui
dobbiamo identificarci è come dire come
dei grandi puzzle cominciare a riempire
dei vuoti che abbiano poi magari di
quelle robe ci stufiamo e legge siamo
via quindi generiamo anche dei rifiuti
materiali non soltanto dei rifiuti
diciamo mentali
e vi posso assicurare che lavorare nei
social è molto complicato perché noi
contro in rientro quindi creatori di
contenuti non solo ci dobbiamo
sottomettere al
alla barbarie dell'algoritmo che decide
deliberatamente cosa le persone devono
vedere o meno ma in più ci dobbiamo
sottoporre al parere di un pubblico
molto volubile che quando non un
contenuto diventa virale
vai una sorta di buco nero in cui
chiunque poi si sente in diritto di
potere dire o fare una cosa e quindi
anche di insultarti io sono sicuro che
anche tra le persone che mi seguono c'è
qualcuno che magari quando mi vede
comparire in video dice mai anche su
villas allineati nuovissimi fa malus
angolo busca fas ma se io ogni volta che
devo pubblicare un contenuto mi
lasciassi soverchiare da questo da
questo pensiero e non potrei pubblicare
nulla o meglio non potrei intanto negare
a me stesso il piacere di fare delle
cose che mi piacciono ma soprattutto
negherei anche alle persone che mi
seguono il piacere l'opportunità di
fruire di quel contenuto e magari di
scoprire qualcosa che può essergli utile
che si possono portare a casa un nuovo
ingrediente un nuovo modo di pt di
vedere di di assaggiare un piatto di
preparare un piatto quindi quando ci
lasciamo soverchiare da una da una paura
dovremmo sempre fare un bilancino tra
cosa rinunciamo a noi stessi cioè per
noi stessi e cosa neghiamo agli altri
molto spesso non contattiamo le persone
perché abbiamo paura di disturbare però
magari quella persona vorrebbe essere
contattata posto perché ciò perché
chimica perché i petali pesano le
chiappe non lo sappiamo questo
io per molti anni ho sofferto gli
attacchi di panico tra l'altro il
primissimo attacco di panico che ha
avuto l'ho avuto a sette anni e
certificata questa cosa proprio un un
record di cui vado molto fiero e sotto
durante la settimana santa a
caltanissetta solo che poi me ne sono
dimenticato nel corso degli anni e poi
il panico ritornato a 21 anni
ci ho messo ben nove anni per
riprendere a
per sistemare un po tutte le cose giunti
a questo punto dobbiamo decidere cosa
fare delle nostre paure se insieme alle
esperienze pregresse
renderle sempre un cioè lasciare il
ruolo di freno che ci impedisce di poter
andare avanti quindi di prendere le
decisioni oppure trasformarle in energia
in benzina che alimenta le nostre
decisioni
io personalmente ad esempio continua a
fare voglio fare il libero proprio
esiste perché ho una paura enorme di
tornare a fare il lavoratore dipendente
che una cosa che detestavo quindi
e la
la qualità quindi questa cosa la
frontera le nostre paure significa anche
curare la nostra ecologia emotiva e
l'ecologia emotiva rientra nella qualità
del nostro monologo interiore le domande
e le parole le frasi che rivolgiamo a
noi stessi
determinano il la qualità della nostra
personalità e la qualità della nostra
personalità determinata anche le azioni
che noi concrete che generiamo che poi
possono essere azioni di crescita o di
decrescita ma se il nostro monologo
interiore e sempre impregnato di paura
dalla necessità di doversi difendere da
questa quell'altro pericolo immaginario
anziché no oppure da tutte quelle volte
che siamo rimasti bloccati da sempre
poco fa io sono rimasto sono rimasto un
po così bloccato ma gli sto rimettendo
nuovamente in gioco per concludere il
mio ted quindi
è ma sono un essere umano raga mica sono
un robot
capita che anche anche noi anche per gli
umani abbiamo l'algoritmo un po che
sfalsa quindi la qualità di quello che
noi diciamo a noi stessi determina la
qualità della nostra personalità è
l'unico morino il grande obiettivo che
dobbiamo
cercare di raggiungere per raggiungere
una crescita che possiamo poi
condividere con gli altri non è la
felicità dal centro commerciale ma
l'equilibrio nella nostra società non si
passa non si parla abbastanza
dell'equilibrio perché è una posizione
intermedia che ti permette di stare qua
mentre tutto intorno al c'è un enorme
caos pronto nel frattempo puoi allungare
la testa a prendere vedere cosa c'è da
questa parte e prenderti questa piccola
cosa che ti servono da tempo poi ti giro
quest'altra parte vedi amo guarda c'è
quest'altra cosa bellissima la posso
combinare con quest'altra guarda che
cosa è successo tieni caro amico
equilibrato cosa tipo ifa cosa puoi fare
tu con quest altra roba e poi diventa
uno scambio continuo la palla torna qui
e poi torna in quella balza da un campo
all'altro
quindi io personalmente sto cercando di
raggiungere il mio equilibrio
affrontando grazie memore della
psicoterapia d'urto della cucina
nell'aver cucinata domicilio del aver
gestito la mia la mia ansia le mie paure
ma senza mai dimenticare qual è stato il
mio iter cosa mi sono portato dalle
esperienze per s da quando facevo il
muratore o quando ho fatto il cameriere
da quando ho scritto musica e questa
cosa mi sta apportando dal
comunque dall'essere stato un muratore
quattordicenne a parlare qui a lui in un
talk quindi c'è anche io sto fatto un
percorso di crescita che sto cercando un
po di trasmettere a questa platea e vi
voglio lasciare con un'ultima domanda
che ha scritto un mio caro amico
federico questo amico federico ha
scritto anni fa un libro che si chiama
così parlò zarathustra
all'interno di questo libro c'è un
capitolo che secondo me credo sia il più
bello di questo libro che si chiama del
dello spirito di gravità e quando ho
letto questa domanda lì per lì ho detto
ma è una domanda molto banale proprio mi
sono fermato un attimo a riflettere ha
detto aspetta non è poi così banale
perché ve la dirò se vi fermate cinque
minuti a riflettere vi si aprirà un
meraviglioso abisso però vi dovete
scrutarlo dovete metterci proprio la
testa dentro questo abisso di ci
potreste anche fare uno shampoo volendo
abisso conosce un po da paura
la domanda che vi rivolgo è la domanda
che di default
questa insomma è la mia strada il mio
iter
dov'è la vostra
compiti per casa io vi ringrazio per
avere avuto pazienza per avermi
ascoltato spero che questi minuti che
abbiamo trascorso insieme voi ad
ascoltarmi sono stato un piccolo
investimento e non un grande spreco
grazie